so Peter we just saw the big windows 10
press conference by Microsoft and there
were a few big gaming announcements in
there and I think some of the big ones
were concerning the xbox one in which
you can now stream to a pc right yeah I
mean Microsoft's always had a hold on
Windows gaming but this is the first
time that they're kind of making it like
a really strong I'd say smart move to
unite PC and Xbox gaming games for
windows live didn't really cut it so
what they're doing now is I've
essentially made it so that xbox one
people can stream their games right to
Windows 10 PC and therefore you can play
the game like let's say if someone's
using your television or kind of like
the PlayStation TV unit you can stream
it to any room in the house which is
pretty useful but they've also gone a
little bit further to unite the Xbox
community with the pc community by
creating the Xbox app within Windows 10
it's essentially like a facebook like
social network where you can comment on
like certain things that people have
shared and it seems like it actually a
good way to bring gamers together where
they haven't really been able to in a
really easy way and the Xbox one now I
think for me the most exciting thing
about that press conference was how they
closed it and that was with Holograms so
you know they've got this whole new so
like Cola lens technology which is
basically an AR device that sits on your
head and essentially you know allows you
to I guess like map things onto the real
world and interact with it they showed
off I guess one sort of gaming
application with that which is minecraft
which looks really cool what did you
think of hollow lens I'm someone who
likes forward-thinking technology and I
think that Microsoft is taking a pretty
strong first step here you have a lot of
devices like you know Sony's project
Morpheus oh the oculus rift headset that
work with separate devices to bring that
experience but microsoft's hololens
headset has its own discrete hardware so
it has its own cpu a separate GPU and
their hologram processing unit in there
to control all of that and it has
connect like technology to sort of sense
the world around you all of those things
add up to a device that's really
intelligent and actually looks like it
performs quite well the demo they had on
stage showed a woman sort of building
something and they put this kit on the
camera so you could also see what she
was seeing
and it was great like it looked like it
was working pretty well and obviously
this is a demo they've tried many times
but if they can iterate upon that grow
it and continue to me a consistent
experience it's going to get huge move
for Microsoft and so many people are
concerned about you know you wear a
headset you're cut off from the world
with their hollow lens technology you're
still seeing through the headset you can
see the real world around you you're not
shutting yourself off and I think that
is one of the most interesting bits like
while companies like Sony and oculus and
going down VR which does close you off
and I guess that was your not be
concerned you know Microsoft technology
has gone in a different direction and
you know it's good that they're trying
to you know put a stake in this in a
unique area you know I'm somewhat
skeptical because you know that demo the
demo that they showed in some of the
videos they showed for hollow lens was
was was great absolutely stunning stuff
and they can actually realize that then
it'll be an amazing piece of tech but I
just think back to you know stuff like
2009 connect demos and you know most
recently lutely Luna room I think it was
called and you know like Microsoft has I
think this sort of history of like you
know having really flashy really you
know promising demos that may not
actually sort of pan out in the end you
do make a good point but at the same
time they did a live demo on stage it
totally worked wired has a piece up
already where they tried out some demos
and they're pretty positive about the
whole thing they say it basically lives
up to what they're talking about the
Microsoft where you have Justin hey Walt
who's going to be trying it out so we'll
have a good idea if these things work
hololens is real they showed it off they
got people trying it today and they have
demos that are compelling right compare
the two oculus pose and they first
started this is a bigger difference and
I think that Microsoft has the right
tools and the right things in place to
make this work okay crazy speculation
time how much is holding is going to be
Hollins is probably going to come out
for i'm going to say between 300 and 400
dollars but we're probably not going to
see it for another two years I'm just
going to clash with be off do you think
is this competing in the same space it
is competing in the same space but only
so far as consumers are concerned which
ultimately is what's most important I
think developers are not going to be
saying well we support oculus and we
support this i mean the very different
technologies and very different ways of
using them but in the consumers mind
it's still a headset it's still sort of
taking nan you know
non-gaming into non-traditional space
and people going to be looking at them
like impeding products so that's a
challenge of Microsoft has to overcome
your very interesting to see if they can
do